ONLINE, IT'S HEADING TOWARDS
SHUTTING DOWN JUST OVER AN HOUR
FROM NOW.
>> Laura: ED HENRY, KEEP US
UPDATED.
NOW WE HAVE TO GO ON TO THE
OTHER STORY.
WE BROUGHT THIS TO YOU A FEW
DAYS AGO, TWO DAYS AFTER WE LEFT
LAS VEGAS, WHERE WE PRESSED FOR
ANSWERS ON THAT WORST MASS
SHOOTING IN U.S. HISTORY.
WE LEARNED A LITTLE MORE TODAY,
INTERESTING.
AFTER REFUSING TO ANSWER OUR
QUESTIONS ON WEDNESDAY, CLARKE
COUNTY SHERIFF JOE LOMBARDO HELD
A PRESS CONFERENCE EARLIER TODAY
AND HE SAID THEY STILL HAVE NO
MOTIVE FOR THE MASSACRE AND
ADDED THIS ABOUT REPORTS OF A
POTENTIAL ACCOMPLICE TO STEPHEN
PADDOCK.
>> I KNOW AND BELIEVE THERE WAS
ONLY ONE SUSPECT WHO KILLED 58
PEOPLE AND INJURED HUNDREDS
MORE.
THERE WAS ONLY ONE PERSON
RESPONSIBLE AND THAT WAS STEPHEN
PADDOCK.
HE HAD LOST A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF HIS MONETARY WEALTH, CLOSE
APPROXIMATITY TO 1 OCTOBER AND
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD AGAINST
MARY LOU DANLEY.
AS TO ANY OTHER PEOPLE, THE FBI
>> Laura: INDIVIDUAL WITH
FEDERAL INTEREST.
VERY, VERY INTERESTING.
LOOKS LIKE A GRAND JURY MAY HAVE
ALREADY BEEN CONVENED TO PURSUE
THIS SOME ONE ELSE WHOSE FAME WE
DON'T KNOW CONNECTED TO THE
HORRIFIC CRIME.
BUT IT'S NOT MARY LOU DANLEY.
>> AS TO ANY OTHER PEOPLE THE
INTEREST.
I WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ELABORATE
ON THAT STATEMENT.
>> Laura: ANOTHER LOVELY TIDBIT
OF INFORMATION, THIS FREAK
PADDOCK HAD MULTIPLE COPY
PADDOCK HAD MULTIPLE COIE
PADDOCK HAD MULTIPLE COIES
PADDOCK HAD MULTIPLE COIES O
PADDOCK HAD MULTIPLE COIES OF
CHILD PORNOGRAPHY ON HIS
COMPUTER.
OFFICIALS ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK
BROTHER IN FLORIDA.
WOW.
JOINING US NOW TO PIECE THIS ALL
TOGETHER, FORMER LAPD DETECTIVE
MARK FUHRMAN IN SAND POINT,
IDAHO, FOLLOWING THE
DEVELOPMENTS N LAS VEGAS THE YOU
ATOR OF "THE POWER REEF
LENTLESS," WAYNE ALLEN ROOT IS
HERE.
LET'S START WITH YOU, WAYNE,
HOMETOWN.
YOU'VE RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT A
POSSIBLE TERRORIST CONNECTION TO
THIS CASE THAT THE FEDS KIND OF
MOVED QUICKLY TO, YOU KNOW,
DISCOUNT EARLY ON.
WHAT DID THAT VERY GOODE ODD
LOMBARDO PRESS CONFERENCE TELL
YOU?
HE LOOKED VERY UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> EVERY PRESS CONFERENCE OF
LOMBARDO HAS BEEN ODD, HE ALWAYS
LOOKS UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE FBI
STASHING DOWN BEHIND HIM.
WE AREN'T GETTING THE ANSWERS WE
DESERVE.
I DON'T KNOW THERE IS A TERROR
CONNECTION.
NOBODY KNOWS THAT.
WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN THE RIGHT
TALK SHOW, NO ONE BELIEVES WHAT
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE FBI, NO ONE
BELIEVES WHAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM
PRESIDENT, WHO I LOVE, YOU KNOW
I'M ONE OF THE BIGGEST FIGHTERS
ON BEHALF OF DONALD TRUMP, BUT
HE LOVES TO WADE INTO
CONTROVERSY AND CRISIS AND
CHAOS.
AND DONALD TRUMP HAS SAID
NOTHING ABOUT THIS.
THIS THAN THEY'RE WILLING TO LET
ON.
I THINK THERE'S SO MUCH MORE
THAT WE WILL LEARN IN THE FUTURE
HAH WE DON'T KNOW RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE NOT GETTING THE RIGHT
>> Laura: MARK FUHRMAN, WE KNOW
IN THE DAYS AFTER THE SHOOTING,
CERTAIN ISIS WEBSITES HAD
CLAIMED THAT STEPH GENERAL
PADDOCK HAD CONVERTED TO ISLAM
SIX MONTHS EARLIER.
NOW WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT HE
HAD IN THAT PHOTO, THE ONLY
PHOTO OF HIM, HE HAS A SHOT
GLASS, IF HE CONVERTED TO ISLAM
COULD THIS BE, COULD THERE BE
THAT POSSIBILITY, GIVEN WHAT WE
KNOW NOW?
>> WELL, LOOK AT THIS.
ISIS WILL TAKE A CLAIM OF ANY
MASS MURDER IN HOPES THAT NOBODY
ELSE WILL CLAIM IT, THEN THEY
GET CREDIT FOR IT, THEN THEY ARE
OF COURSE TERRORISTS AND THAT
CREATES TERROR.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS, YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE.
THAT'S ALL WE CAN DEAL WITH, IS
THE EVIDENCE.
YOU CAN MAKE THEY ARIES, YOU CAN
BUT UNTIL YOU HAVE EVIDENCE YOU
CAN'T MAKE ANY KIND OF
CONCLUSION THAT THAT'S WHAT
OCCURRED.
THE EVIDENCE HERE IS WE HAD A
THAT IS ALL THAT THEY CAN
>> IF THERE'S A CONSPIRATOR,
SOME DAY --
>> Laura: MARK, I JUST KEEP
MY FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS ARE
PHOTOGRAPHIC EVIDENCE.
VIDEOTAPE.
I KNOW WHEN YOU CHECK IN TO
EVERY HOTEL, AND WAYNE CAN YOU
CHIME IN ON THIS, YOU ARE
VIDEOED EVERY STEP OF THE WAY IN
LAS VEGAS.
THERE ARE CAMERAS EVERYWHERE.
EVERYWHERE.
WHY HAVE WE NOT SEEN ANY OF THAT
MATERIAL?
I AGREE WITH YOU, EVIDENCE
RULES.
BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF
TRANSPARENCY WHAT ARE PEOPLE TO
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE A
GUY WHO'S 60-SOMETHING YEARS OLD
WAS RUNNING BETWEEN TWO, YOU
KNOW, PEDESTALS TO SHOOT, PEOPLE
DIFFERENT, THEY THOUGHT THERE
WERE TWO DIFFERENT SHOOTERS OF
THE MULTIPLE WITH ITS SAID THAT.
THE GUY IS SPRUNTING RUNNING
BETWEEN GUN POSITIONS?
I'M NOT -- YOU'RE AN EXPERT,
MARK.
WHEN THE HOTEL DOESN'T RELEASE
THE CHECK-IN PHOTOS, VIDEO,
NOTHING.
WE GOT -- THE GUY HAS NO -- THE
ODD.
MARK, THEN WAYNE.
>> WELL, LOM BAR GO, HE --
LOMBARDO STATED, I THINK, 25,000
FEET OR 25,000 VIDEO SEGMENTS
THAT THEY ACTUALLY REVIEWED.
YOU CAN SEE THE VOLUME OF WORK
THEY HAVE HAD TO GO THROUGH IN
ONCE AGAIN, YOU DO NOT HAVE A
HOMICIDE INVESTIGATION AND A
PROSECUTION.
BUT YOU HAVE CIVIL LITIGATION,
YOU HAVE DISCOVERY THERE.
POLICE ARE PROBABLY GOING TO BE
TO DO THIS AND FAILURE TO DO
THAT, THAT'S WHAT ATTORNEYS DO.
SO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SHARE
THIS AND POLLUTE THE JURY POOL
UNTIL THOSE ISSUES ARE SETTLED.
>> LAURA, CAN I JUMP IN?
>> Laura: YES.
>> IT'S NOT 1963.
MAYBE AMERICANS BELIEVED THE JFK
STORY IN 1963 BUT NOBODY IN
LAS VEGAS OR ANYWHERE IN THE
COUNTRY, MY SHOW IS NATIONAL,
NONE OF THE CALLERS BELIEVE THIS
STORY.
I COULD TELL YOU, MAKES NO SENSE
THAT THE POLICE IN LAS VEGAS DID
NOT PUT THIS IN THE HANDS OF THE
HOMICIDE DIVISION WITH 35
SEASONED HOMICIDE COPS WHO
STUDIED MURDERS THEIR WHOLE
LIFE.
THEY PUT IT IN LANDS OF FIVE
POLICE OFFICERS WHO STUDY
ACCIDENTAL SHOOTINGS BY THE
POLICE.
EXPLAIN HOW A GUY AT 60 WAKES UP
THE SHOOTING SUDDENLY JARED
KUSHNER WAS SENT TO SAUDI ARABIA
THAT'S ANY CONNECTION.
>> THE DIPLOMATIC POUCH, KING OF
SAUDI ARABIA, WITHIN DAYS, 300